um I hear that you're also a jack caroak
fan I am which is I feel like you're so
young for that but that's cool I feel
like that's the only time that you're
supposed to be a jack carck fan is like
when you're young and then maybe when
you're old you can re you can revisit um
but yeah yeah I kind of found you know
on the road at the right time 18 19 uh
you know going to America leaving home
you know I've got like fire in my feet
and you know I'm trying to find the
feeling and in things so it was um it
was like a companion you know novel to
my s coming to America and everything
like that yeah that was Jane a for me
that what changed me yeah that was just
that I love that book it just like I
felt it because I moved out to LA before
Idol or whatever and and I got very
lonely like I can get lonely really
quickly so I it's nice to have things
like that yeah that was that was the
there's the this section in car's book
because he's going and going and
traveling across America searching for
his pal and sort of towards the end he's
so sort of tired and weary and there's
just one sentence and it's highlighted
in my copy of it and he said I wish I
could see someone that had known me for
more than 5 minutes and that's
paraphrasing it or something like that
but that was the line that like that
really kind of rocked me from that book
you know this idea of having someone
that knows your like soul and movements
not just kind of yeah uh who you are or
what you've done or you know that I had
to like train myself to be good at small
talk I was not that was not my thing I'm
amazing at it now but like I had to like
train myself cuz I'm deeply like I like
want to know everything and I want to
get in a real conversation and know
someone and that's really hard for me to
do I just sort of will walk away yeah
I'm in that I'm in the if you act
strange enough people want
like he's odd you're like yeah I'll get
away with it I'm get away with OD you
know I love
[Music]
that
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home